[Musique]
bonne nouvelle a répété il n'y a aucune
raison de douter que les vaccins
protègent contre le variant au micron
omicron voilà la déclaration de l' oms
les vaccins seraient de serait donc très
efficace je m'attends à ce que les
vaccins dont nous disposons actuellement
soit efficace contre les maladies graves
et les hospitalisations nous devons
mesurer cela est confirmé que c'est le
cas selon une première étude sud
africaine publié hier le vaccin serait
40 fois moins efficace contre mikron
pour l'instant c'est un rappel
mais plus de fait qu'il en faudra un
quatrième
je ne sais pas malheureusement il y à
une baisse de l'efficacité
du vaccin qui al'air importante
autrement dit les anticorps
neutralisants suscité par le vaccin
neutralisent beaucoup moins bien ce
variant au micro l'ovation unanime du
parlement allemand pour angela merkel à
faire pâlir d'envié les dirigeants du
monde entier
mc ronde battu par pécresse tout est
parti du sondage dont je vous parlais
hier la surprise était donc totale pour
toutes les chaînes qui ont appris la
nouvelle à 18 heures et juste avant elle
commentait d'autres sondages qui disent
l inverse et les sondages ça va et vient
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est de
sentir qu'il ya une envie l'alternance
dans le pays ce n'est qu'un début et il
faut que j'aille convaincre les français
comme le disait pas valérie pécresse
elle-même il y a quelques jours de cela
que les sondages ça va ça vient c'est
comme la queue du chien c'était ses
propres mots j'arrête de regarder tout
ça et je conserve
sur ces sujets comme il ya d'ailleurs un
mois ou un mois et demi beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de recul on a de
droite qui sont fondamentalement
irréconciliables on le voit bien moi je
pense que c'est vous la voyez et des
droits skyward sword pour aller droit au
but je pense que la droite avec ce qui
finira chez emoa le pen et la gauche est
très faible qu'il faut absolument aussi
que les les thèmes qui sont les thèmes
principaux n'a pas en réalité on a parlé
de santé on parle de l'école on parle de
pouvoir d'achat ces thèmes là
aujourd'hui n'occupe pas suffisamment le
débat public pour y inviter ya huit
jours ou moyer pas parler de monsieur
zemmour aujourd'hui vous me parlez à
nombre de selles et dans l'actualité par
ce parce que nous avons eu une campagne
primaire des républicains où tout le
monde a été sur la surenchère ayant pour
modèle monsieur zemmour la conséquence
que j'en tire c'est qu'il faut organiser
une primaire de cette gauche arbitré par
nos concitoyens je sais qu'ils seront
très nombreux plus de foie gras dans les
réceptions officielles à lyon la mairie
écologistes estiment en effet que la
production de foie gras ne permet pas
d'assurer le bien-être animal la vie
n'en commandes plus depuis l'automne
2020 l'histoire nous nous gagnons à la
respecter à l'apprendre à permettre à
nos historienne d'historiens sur la base
de toutes races de documents de
construire une vérité historiographique
et gardons nous de la manipuler
je voulais jt de la revoir falentin m et
27 ans était encarté chez les
républicains depuis début novembre ils
avaient voté pour eric ciotti au
deuxième tour du congrès il avait été
placé en garde à vue pour violences avec
préméditation dimanche sa ministre
marlène schiappa est récompensé oui elle
reçoit le grand prix de l'humour
politique pour cette petite phrase on ne
va pas s'interdire des plans à trois je
suis fier d'être ici avec vous en france
en france où une ministre peut rappeler
qu'on a le droit d'être mélange is
libertin abstinent bisexuels marié
fidèles divorcés trois fois marié avec
une personne du même sexe sans attaches
salchaud sexuelle ou même soliste voir
tout ça à la fois voir ça dépend des
jours je suis un militant de l'humour en
politique je pense que c'est très
important de cultiver la distance que
notre monde aujourd'hui est en train de
devenir violent et que c'est la
disparition de l'humour qui annonce des
temps difficiles